it's a teaching Hot Topic artificial
intelligence might be the stuff of
Science Fiction but in classrooms it's
also becoming the reality with potential
to transform the way we teach and learn
century is an intelligent intervention
tool that's able to understand each
student's individual strengths
weaknesses and behaviors Priya lakhani
set up the world's first AI platform for
schools and colleges she believes it's a
teaching tool which increases outcomes
it benefits the teacher because it gives
them those instant insights so they can
make those timely interventions and it
benefits the student because they no
longer have to be stuck it will
personalize learning for them figure out
whether gaps in knowledge are figures
out where they need to stretch and
provide that instantly to the student
but not all AI is equal and what's
worrying teaches is generative AI
platforms like chat GPT which create new
content the government has shown very
little interest in AI in education now
suddenly chat GPT is there and they are
taking a lot of interest and it's very
very hard to tell what is authentic
student work and what is generated by
generative uh Ai and that problem is
going to grow
exponentially and parents agree clearer
regulations a priority for pupil safety
I think we just need to kind of explore
a bit more and understand how we can
maybe put some controls around it you
can't really take it back now isn't it
because that that's what they've learned
so you have to really integrate that
into their life there was idea All Tech
is good and everything's just come in
without any debate without any you know
the same with social media and we're the
big experiment our children are the big
experiment a spokesperson for the
Department for Education said artificial
intelligence offers cutting-edge
opportunities for schools and has the
power to transform teachers day-to-day
lives including the potential to reduce
workload the education secretary has
been clear about the government's
appetite to pursue the significant
opportunities and manage the risks that
exist in this space and we've already
published information to help schools do
this
but teachers say the response is too
slow for a fast-moving technology
they're demanding guidance to help
maximize the benefits and mitigate the
dangers Laura bundock Sky News